[Music]
tigrerra turns 40 tomorrow she
celebrated with some of her fellow Black
Panther stars tonight is just one of
them fierce females in this movie Nancy
oh yeah take a backseat to any man
and I'll be your sidekicks they're far
from sidekicks the warrior the spy the
scientist and the queen Black Panthers
nothing without these powerful women
Angela Bassett is the widowed wakandan
queen and real-life husband Courtney
Vance was in total awe of her big Marvel
movie oh this is kind of a movie that I
love you know I have to get by fix with
this kind of when it comes to sheer girl
power The Walking Dead's Danai gurira is
the fierce leader of wakanda's elite
all-female fighting force and Lupita
Nyong'o well she's got mad spy skills
the two shared a Broadway stage in 2016
and even though they both already signed
on to star in black panther they had no
idea the other one was in until director
Ryan Coogler came to a performance do
you know it's all top secrecy until Ryan
came to see eclipsed right and then he
said yo yo girls she's at it too I
looked at each other really okay
for latisha right taking on the role of
tech-savvy little sister was a
no-brainer I think we can consider her a
Disney Princess hey man what can I say
no I just I'm just gonna make sure and
I'll be a humble princess although in a
reputation be the crazy you know there
are so many people looking forward to
the movie in fact our good buddy Sheryl
Underwood from the talk bought out an
entire year to make for some skits and
Ellie got to see this movie this weekend
for free and actually Octavia Spencer is
doing the same thing Stephanie I allow
my families and underserved communities
to see the movie I love that an awesome
[Music]
you
[Music]